-Amanda Gorman. I'm so excited
to have you here.
-I'm so excited to be here.
You know, this is my first
in-person
night talk show ever, so --
-Is that right?
-Yes!
-Wow. I'm honored. I'm honored.
You look gorgeous.
-Thank you.
-And I got to see you
the other night at the Met Gala,
and you looked gorgeous
that night as well, by the way.
-Thank you. Oh, wow.
-Here's a photo of you.
Can you talk me through it?
-Of course.
Well, the theme of the night
was basically American fashion,
and so I came to my team
with this idea
of being a reimagined
Statue of Liberty,
but I really wanted
to leaning into kind of
the poetry of the statue.
So, for example,
having a laurel crown,
which poets would wear
in ancient Greece.
That's also where the title
"poet laureate" comes from,
and I was honored to be
a poet laureate in my life.
Also bringing a bag
which looks like a book
because I love reading
wherever I go
and making sure that I had,
you know, a line from the poem
at the base of the statue.
So truly, like, try to walk
in the words of what it means
to welcome the world
to the United States.
-I loved it.
I thought it was so --
-Thank you.
-So much thought and so --
-I was telling you backstage
I was watching the inauguration.
You blew us all away.
That was one of
the most impressive things
I've ever seen.
-Thank you. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Knocked it out of the park.
-Thank you.
-It was such an amazing job,
and I know that you got to meet
eventually Lin-Manuel Miranda,
who -- You kind of loosely
based a couple of the lines
in the poem
based off of "Hamilton."
Did you get a chance
to meet him and...?
-Yeah, so, the incredible thing
is I actually met Lin
several years ago,
and I was so nervous,
I almost threw up on him.
He does not know this.
But I wrote him a poem
of what I would say
if I could articulate words
to him in person, and he said,
"I'm going to keep this
for, you know, I can say,
'I knew you when...'"
And, you know, basically
we're at the point now.
He was like, "I knew you when!"
We've arrived there.
He's been so great.
-See? He's a magical guy.
I love that he did that.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, "I'm gonna keep this
'cause one day
I'm going to say,
'I knew you when.'"
-Yeah, and he's, like,
three years later, on the dot.
-"I knew you when."
All right. That's great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I read somewhere -- Yeah.
I read somewhere
that you decided
that you're going to
run for president.
-Yes.
-In 2030...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Thank you.
-In 2036.
-Yes.
-All right, so we have
some time, but you always knew
that you wanted
to run for president?
-Yes, so, if you don't know,
2036 is the year
in which I will be old enough
to actually run for president,
but I've known that
for quite some time.
I was like 9 or 10,
and I came home. I was like,
"You know, Mom, I want to change
some things in this world,
so I'm going to
run for president."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And...
-That's fantastic.
-And I have such
an incredible mom
that she knew
this wasn't a joke.
She knew it wasn't
kind of an idle word
that I kind of tossed out
just for giggles.
And so, you know, my family
has been so dedicated to it.
For example, if I'm ever
at a party with my twin sister
and people are taking photos,
she's like,
"Unh-uh-unh-unh. My sister
is running for president.
Put your phone down."
So they know
the campaign is real,
and, you know,
we just really orient
our lives living toward
best values
because we know
at one point in time
I will aspire to the highest
seat of power in the country,
so got to be prepared.
-I think you're gonna do it.
I think you're
gonna go all the way.
I want to talk about your book,
"Change Sings."
First of all,
congratulations on this.
This went to --
-Thank you.
-This shot up on Amazon
right after you did --
It wasn't even out.
-Yeah.
-They were like, "Oh, and
she might put this book out."
It was like, whoosh, number one.
But anyways, it is --
I have two --
I have two little girls, but --
And they have school,
and I know this is going to be
the best book in their school.
They're going to love this.
It is such a great message
to every kid out there.
And I also love
the illustrations
and what happens with this poem.
[ Fingers snapping ]
Yes, yes, yes.
-I'm a poet,
so I do this all the time.
It makes no sense.
-Yeah. Yeah, I love it.
You go, snap, snap, snap.
We can all snap.
[ Audience snapping fingers ]
That sounds good.
That means
you're destroying right now.
So -- But I love how
it's one person starting change,
and then the band slowly grows,
and there's doubters along
the way and there's haters.
And they -- You change them
around, switch them around.
By the end, you have this
beautiful band of kids
all singing
and making change together.
-They're like The Roots.
-They're kind of like -- Yeah.
-Literally.
-They are like The Roots.
Yeah, they are like The Roots.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Would it be okay if I asked you
to read some of the book to us?
-Yes, of course.
-I don't know where you --
-Thank you.
I'll start.
-Yeah, tell me
where you want to start.
-This is kind of the middle.
-Okay.
-"Though some
don't understand it,
those windmills of mysteries,
I sing with all the planet
in its hills of histories.
I'm bright as the light
each day brings.
There is love
where my change sings."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Every library, every school,
every kid, get this book.
Amanda Gorman!
-Thank you.
"Change Sings:
A Children's Anthem,"
is available right now.
And she will be president
one day.